i can't believe i get to say this but we
finally
have optic gaming back it's been a long
time since optic resembled the org that
so many of us remember but with hex back
in the driver's seat
there's finally some good news for call
of duty
having names like hex optic and nadeshot
involved in the call of duty league is
important
but maybe even better is the fact that
the new cod title cold war
is getting some pretty good reviews from
the pros add it all together and
it looks like 2021 could be the best
year for cod
in a long time
[Music]
alright guys so if you haven't already
hit that subscribe button
ring the notification bell and let us
know in the comments below
if there's any story that you personally
are following
if you've got a great idea for a story
and you want to reach out to us
you can contact us at our tips email at
tips at thescore.com
today cod fans have a lot to celebrate
and i'm not just talking about the
midnight release of cold war the series
newest entry
on wednesday hex announced that not only
had he purchased the optic name
but that the team previously known as
the huntsman would be rebranded to the
chicago optic
what's going on guys big optics here
yes that means the green wall is
officially back
the acquisition had been reported before
in october you will get nothing out of
me
i am a brick wall when it comes to this
kind of stuff
um yeah i have no information
green wall but i'm tess
i have no information for you on this
subject
but the fact that the optic name would
be attached to a cdl slot was
new as was the announcement this is huge
for a number of reasons
even if you don't care about call of
duty first
optic is one of the absolute goats in
the cod space
but they're also a pioneer of gaming
content generally
we're talking about a company that went
from a tiny online sniping clan
to the greatest dynasty in cod history
the curse has been broken
the dynasty has been cemented
they are the greatest monster in call of
duty history
but more than just competitive results
optic absolutely changed the way that we
think about esports
gaming content and how they intersect
look
optic and hex were way ahead in the
content game
it's not enough to just have an
extremely competitive team of players
who are great at what they do you have
to give fans a reason
to actually care about those players
optic was doing that
making fans care about their players
whether they were playing cod or
minecraft
over a decade ago and their fans who
became known as the green wall
were some of the most dedicated in
esports and if you
are an optic fan that's probably why the
2019 sale of optic
to immortals stung so much hex had
already sold a controlling stake in
optic to
parent company infinite esports and
entertainment
in 2017 but he stayed on
he was still part of the org's identity
he said that he started to warn in early
2019 that
things that infinite were getting a
little unsustainable
and he actually submitted a bid to try
to buy optic back
himself but was shut down then the bid
from immortals came in in 2019 to buy
all of infinite including optic and when
hex and immortals couldn't agree to
terms for a continued role with the
organization
it looked like it might actually be the
end everybody's freaking out everybody's
freaking out about the future of optic
that it might be dissolved that it won't
exist anymore
obviously i think that'd be very dumb
from a mortal standpoint because optic
is such a powerful branch
i've seen creatures what it wouldn't put
it past anybody to do
just nonsensical stuff so once immortals
took it over
hex joined nrg becoming co-ceo
alongside andy miller but for optic fans
the time
since that purchase hasn't exactly been
worthy of celebrating
in fact for many fans it looked like the
optic that they had come to know and
love
was basically gone the optic name was
removed from the league of legends team
and though it did continue to exist as
the name of the
lacdl spot it had no real connection to
hex which
fans noticed representing la
give it up for optic gaming
in fact i'm willing to bet that a lot of
optic fans defected to nrg's team
the chicago huntsman the old optic
might have been dead but skump sure
wasn't
after the move that left hex an optic
separate
cod esports was in this weird position
they had this
brand new sparkly franchise league but
many of the faces that had helped to
make cod esports what it is today
weren't present in it sure we had the
atlanta phase
but without hex optic and nadeshot
it just didn't feel right this year the
chicago slot and the cdl
will be using the optic name but even
without it
hex said on a recent podcast that the
chicago huntsmen
were actually very close to being
profitable
minus the pricey franchising fees i mean
we were super close
to being a break even business i mean
minus obviously the the the fee that
goes
into into you know paying the the
franchise fees but we were
this close from being a break-even
business on year
freaking one with the con with the with
the people that we have
next year without a doubt we're hitting
those numbers i i get i promise that
we're gonna get to be a i'm gonna call
it and we're gonna be profitable whether
it's a dollar or two dollars or whether
it's 300 we're gonna do that because
with this year we're this
freaking close energy i know it's easy
for your eyes to glaze over when we
start talking about the money but what
i'm really saying here
is chicago was doing well without the
optic name
having it will only help them for long
time fans of optic
having the name back in the game's
biggest league is a kind of vindication
we've got optic skunk back baby
yo yo yo what is going on everybody it's
your boy optics comfy
the dark times are over optic and hex
are reunited and
honestly it's what cod deserves if you
kept the faith through everything and
still consider yourself part of the
green
wall you earned this dub enjoy it
and all the ones yet to come okay so
optic is back
but there's still more huge news for cod
because the la slot that hex
bought before this unveil has been sold
to an apparel company
okay okay it's just a joke all right
it's just a joke it was sold to esports
orc hundred thieves
whose owner nade shot is one of esports
biggest success
how the stories you doing nate out here
what up guys
big option x here this horrible
depiction of vietra he sounds like a
nerd when he does it
though hundred thieves has struggled to
find a dominant roster in any esport
you can't win if you don't play listen
i'll admit my bias and say that
i'm a fan of nade he's been a pioneer
for esports in a lot of ways
like i literally [ __ ] wrote and
voiced a 20 minute video about him
but honestly it kind of hurt to see
someone who's given
so much to call of duty stuck on the
outside
when hundred thieves announced that they
wouldn't be part of the inaugural call
of duty league
it was a big blow 100 thieves will not
be a part of competitive call of duty
next year
we will not be a part of the cdl we will
not have a team competing for
our brand and that's because while yeah
hundred thieves has picked up teams
all over esports we all sort of knew
that call of duty was really where
nade's heart was
the announcement video by the way was
like a love letter man
he didn't even try to hide it
yo matt you good
yeah i'm good
[Music]
so the la thieves have some sick
branding and someone who really cares
about call of duty in their corner
not to mention nade's substantial
streaming audience
who now have a new reason to tune in to
cdl
and this move means that made and hex
two of the biggest
cheerleaders for call of duty will now
be involved in the league
and in my opinion that's huge for the
future of the cdl
listen i love the branding of teams like
the toronto
ultra or the london royal ravens
but having teams like optic and hundred
thieves involved
is critical to bring more eyes to the
league it gives
credibility to the league and might help
bring in some people who
might have been put off by the
artificial sounding names
it's good for the league as a whole okay
i alluded to this at the beginning of
the video but there's one more thing
that can make this the best year of call
of duty
ever the game itself uh the game played
great especially for an alpha
you know it's uh it's in a good spot so
i'm very excited for
for next year's season and the game it
in general
okay so some people are a little bit
upset about the addition of skill-based
matchmaking
it's an issue that the next call of duty
will have to consider
carefully and honestly i'm not opposed
to just having separate
casual and ranked modes you know the
thing that most competitive games
have had forever but outside of that
most of the pros
seem genuinely excited by it yeah
there's obviously the hype that comes
with the release of any new game
but changes to modern warfare's movement
along with some generally solid gun play
and maps
means that this is a good foundation for
the call of duty league to build on
it's really looking like 2021 could be
the biggest year of call of duty yet
both in and outside the league if you're
a fan of the franchise
this is great news and if you're not
well
get completely and if you're not then
well maybe you just don't know it yet
let's do it again
so hype hyped
i can't believe i get to say this but
i can't believe i get to say this but
don't use this in the end board colton
please holy [ __ ]
dude dude promise me unmute your mic
right now unmute your mic colton
and promise that you won't do this to me
i'm sorry josh
sometimes these things are out of my
hands
i felt like i was [ __ ] channeling
devin like i felt like the mauled enter
my veins
i don't want to say i don't want to say
feel them inside of me
because that i definitely don't want to
say that i mean i just said it on
i just said it on the recording so i'm
probably [ __ ]
real